jedes jahr werden zahlreiche nazi
aufmärsche und aktionen bekommt wer
hindert oder genutzt um sie gegen sich
selbst auszuspielen ein wichtiges thema
und deswegen jetzt die besten fünf
aktionen gegen nazis vor drei jahren
startete die bundeszentrale für
politische bildung einer aktion die sie
schnell im ganzen internet verbreitete
youtuber gegen nazis mehrere große
youtube kanäle aus deutschland unter
anderem bullshit tv alexy baxi und
dickes ding veröffentlichten eine
parodie zum lied hey mister nazi vom
blumio in ihrer eigenen version des
songs äußerten die youtuber ihre
verständnislosigkeit bezüglich rassismus
und versuchten ihre jungen
zuschauerschaft davon zu überzeugen wie
uncool die rechte ideologie ist dickes
ding deutschen tv und alexei beck sie
erreichten mit ihrem videos zusammen
mehr als 1,5 millionen menschen
wer sich gegen rechts einsetzen möchte
aber keinen blassen schimmer hat wo und
wie kann sich eine ganz bestimmte app
herunterladen berlin gegen nazis stellt
eine app bereit die dich informiert wann
und wo nazis veranstaltung abhalten oder
wann und wo gegen kundgebungen
stattfinden eine in der app integrierte
interaktive karte für dich so zu sagen
wie ein navigationssystem dahin wo du
gegen rechts aktiv werden kannst jede
meldung der app wird sorgfältig
überprüft damit die nutzer gewissenhaft
mit informationen versorgt werden leider
gibt es diese app derzeit nur für die
deutsche hauptstadt berlin wer sich die
app downloaden möchte findet in der
video beschreibung die links zu android
und ios
gegen den spruch unwissenheit schützt
vor strafe nicht möchte recht gegen
rechts etwas tun
auf der homepage recht gegen rechts see
findet ihr sozusagen allerhand wie man
gegen die rechte szene vorgehen kann
besonders wichtig dabei ist erst einmal
rechte menschen und oder aktionen in
seinem umfeld wahrzunehmen um nicht
unbewusst der energie ausgesetzt zu sein
oder sie sogar zu vertreten und sich im
schlimmsten fall strafbar zu machen
rechte versuchen durch versteckte
botschaften in musik oder ähnlichem ihre
überzeugung zu verbreiten
nur wer diese kennt kann gegen die
verbreitung solcher inhalte vorgehen
recht gegen rechts klärt umfassen
darüber auf mit welchen kniffen rechte
arbeiten die link zu recht gegen rechts
er findet ihr in der video beschreibung
die geschichte vom trojanischen pferd
kennt wohl wirklich jeder von uns
ansonsten google exit deutschland hat
sich eine moderne variante einfallen
lassen kein riesiges holzpferd sondern t
shirts von außen sagen die shirts aus
wie schützt die jeder rechte gerne hätte
das nutze exit deutschland aus am 6
august 2011 verschenkten sie die shirts
auf den rechten rock für deutschland
festival die beschenkten werden sich
nach dem ersten waschen ihres neuen
oberteils bestimmt an den kopf gefasst
haben auf dem shirt stand nämlich nicht
rat cor rebellen national und frei
sondern was dein t shirt kann kannst du
auch hunderte zeitungen berichteten
sowohl national als auch international
von der gelungenen aktion gelungen war
auch die nächste aktion ebenso von exit
deutschland organisiert mit sprüchen wie
wenn das der führer wüsste oder flink
wie windhunde zäh wie leder und
großzügig wie nie und netzes jahr nazis
in wunsiedel begrüßt bericht zu dem
unfreiwilligen spendenlauf deutschlands
und siedelt wird jährlich von den nazis
besucht warum sie gedenken hitlers
stellvertreter rudolf heß seine
ruhestätte befand sich also seine letzte
ruhestätte sein grab befand sich in
wunsiedel 2014 wurde der gedenkstein
benutzt um rechten beim ausstieg zu
helfen jeder marschierte meter bedeutete
zehn euro für das aussteigerprogramm
exit deutschland die nazis lieben also
nicht gegen die zeit sondern gegen sich
selbst am ende des spendenlaufs standen
10.000 euro auf dem scheck für exit
deutschland super und dieses mal ist es
wieder soweit die nazis marschieren und
spenden mehr oder weniger unfreiwillig
gegen sich selbst in bad nenndorf da
gibt es den neuen lauf gegen die nazis
dieses jahr heißt es ein minute
demonstrieren 10 euro gegen die nazis
von pixum science fiction möchten wir
diese arbeit gegen rechts unterstützen
aussehen grund findet ihr alle links zu
den genannten aktionen in der video
beschreibung und hier oben da genau zur
berichterstattung von was geht ab sie
waren heute in bad nenndorf vor ort und
hier unten könnt ihr für excel
deutschland spenden und schon heute
einen beitrag gegen rechts leisten und
dann muss ich jetzt an dieser stelle mal
sagen dass man ja doch
bis dann bleibt dran